هناك هدوء سلمي في هذا
الممر الصغير الجميل الذي يأخذك فوق
بركة كوي الآن عندما
تفكر في الفوضى التي
تأتي غالبًا مع السفر الجوي ، هذا واحد من
خمسة ما يسمونه حدائق الصين
في العلامة التجارية-  مطار بكين الجديد في بكين
، تم فتحه للتو للجمهور
وهي الميزات عالية التقنية التي
يتحدث عنها الجميع حقًا ، لذا
دعنا نأخذك إلى الداخل لنظهر لك هذا
هو الردهة الدولية ، إنها واحدة
من خمسة ملاعب - إنها موجودة
هنا و  ما تشعر به حقًا بمجرد
دخولك بكين هو
التصميم العصري الأنيق الذي قام به
المهندس المعماري الراحل زها حديد ولكن ما
يروج له المسؤولون حقًا حول هذا المطار
هو التكنولوجيا بمجرد دخولك بشكل
صحيح عند تسجيل الوصول
يبدأ التعرف على الوجه في حقيبتك ويستمر
بينما تسير عبر الأمان
الأمني الذي يقولون إنه أسرع بكثير وأ
ثر كفاءة بسبب التكنولوجيا لم
ذهبوا إلى الكثير من ال
فاصيل حول  القبعة ولكن تقنية التعرف على الوجه
تستمر لأنك على استعداد
لتحملها عند بوابتك
، فلديهم شاشات تلتقط
صورتك وتستمر على طول الطريق
حتى تمر على طائرتك ،
وهي واحدة من أهم الوجبات السريعة  من
dachang هو الحجم الضخم ، فهم
يقدرون 97 ملعبًا لكرة القدم أو حوالي
مائة ملعب كرة قدم أمريكي إذا كنت
ستدخل في الداخل ، لذلك عندما
تفكر في حجم المطار الذي
تفكر فيه بشكل صحيح ، فهذا دائمًا
يمثل تحديًا خاصة إذا كان لديك  لنفترض
أنك وصلت إلى هنا في e85 وعليك
الوصول إلى ردهة أخرى ، فإن الحجة هي
أنه نظرًا لأن شكل نجم البحر
هذا يمكنك بشكل أساسي الانتقال من
مجسّة واحدة والوصول إلى المركز الرئيسي ،
يتجادلون في غضون ثماني دقائق تقريبًا وهذا
ما
يقولون  سوف تأخذ في المتوسط حتى يقولون إن هذ
سيوفر الوقت حقًا في نه
ية المطاف ، ولكن بشكل عام ، هذا هو الجديد ال
ي تشعر بأن هذه التكنولوجيا العالية تحيط به
هذا شيء يقولون إنه مس
مر  حتى على المدرج ،
يقول المسؤولون هنا أن لديهم نظام استشعار
يمكنه اكتشاف سنتيمترين
من جسم من الحطام الذي قد يكون
على المدرج ، ويمكنهم بعد ذلك تكبيره
بكاميرات متعددة لمعرفة مكانه بالضبط
،
لذا فإن التكنولوجيا العالية هي كل شيء  في هذا
المكان ،
يتزامن كل هذا مع
الذكرى السبعين لتأسيس
الصين الشيوعية في الواقع لافتتاح هذا المطار الجديد ، كان
الرئيس شي جين بينغ نفسه
هنا ، حيث كان لديه حشد من
كبار الشخصيات الكثير من مسؤولي المطار
حيث بدأوا هذا الفصل الجديد.  في
السفر الجوي هنا في بكين في النهاية ،
من المتوقع أن يكون لدى بكين أكبر
عدد من المسافرين جواً والركاب
القادمين عبر هذه المدينة أكثر من أي مكان
آخر في العالم David Culver CNN
Beijing